joining us now is Russian broadcaster
Vladimir Posner and former director of
the CIA and NSA General Michael Hayden
good see both his way my goodness me
this is fantastic complicated for all of
us to follow the twists and turns of
who's loyal to who but I guess at the
nub of it the fear is the Russia either
officially backed by the state or
unofficially had been influencing the
situation America and also possibly the
UK too how worried should we be that is
laughing at this by the way which is it
a great start are you laughing because
you know it happens or you laughing
because it's a great advantage other two
crazy question in yes yes and you
shouldn't be worried at all
there's no way that Russian propaganda
can really influence the American voter
or the British folder with that you know
why no I can't hacking into the system
we know how how doing even our election
campaign has been all sorts of targeting
because you can influence yourself I
mean your immediate for instance
obviously influences your your Watchers
because you're part of this country
but when a foreign country tries to
influence it it backfires it never works
seeking that's that you then get the it
back for at this time because I'm sure
Hillary Clinton would disagree
well it didn't BEC backfire with regard
to the impact on the election which I
think was significant now it's
immeasurable all right so we are very
careful back home to say the exact
influence on the campaign is not just
unknown it is unknowable so president
Trump is unarguably the legitimate
President of the United States but
there's no question you had the entire
American intelligence community with a
high confidence judgment point out this
sequence of events in which the data was
stolen weaponized pushed back into the
American political process and then
trolled heavily trolled by agents of the
Russian Federation to pull it forward
inside social media inside general
social consciousness and let me
compliment the Russians this was a
magnificent covert influence campaign
and invite more does have one point all
right knock over it influence covert
influence rarely creates a fracture
in a society covert influence succeeds
when it's aware of and exploits
pre-existing fractures in a society and
that's exactly what the Russian services
did give them credit they knew us at
least as well as we knew ourselves okay
so what are we actually talking about
here you know we've become aware haven't
we in our British selection of these
women
the robot Mather means and things where
people can tweet from fake sources now a
robot I'm going to be a mouse when it
could be a young individual exactly Anna
very matter all of that kind of thing
goes on is that what you're talking
about is part of the overall okay
there's a variety of tools and
magnificently synchronized beginning
with almost certainly using Russian
criminal gangs to steal the original
information the DNC Democratic National
Committee emails John Podesta emails and
so on pulled them back into the hands of
the Federation the Russian Federation
where they at their own choosing then
push it in accordance with their rhythm
their sense of rhythm of the American
electoral process so for example the
massive conch the first dump of
information takes place as as the party
is gathering for its National Convention
that's not accidental saliva I mean
listening to Michael said and then that
was there I must say one thing there's
no proof and then the ice a whole I mean
come on if you have this proof put it on
the table and make it very clear that
this is what the Russians were done I
mean they must be jumping up and down
with joy different agencies have
separated but yeah but that's cute eggs
in the states have said so worried it
was able to said it and the Russians
have said no and if the American word
for some reason more to be believed in
the Russian one I say show me after
we're journalists right yes show me and
not then I'll accept it but I can't see
it are you and the reason why people try
to believe it without pretty fish
because there is a sense that rather if
you would like to do that very good like
you know a certain it feels like there's
a very strong anti-russian sentiment in
the West
it hasn't been born today it's been
around for a long time
minute you say Russian people kind of
react to it and that's why they're prone
to believe it and that's the way they've
been conditioned ad in Russia people are
prone to believe that when you say
American it's something negative this is
what the media have done by the way in
both countries and not only that but the
politician it's interesting you say that
though because it seems that the Western
values that we have seen to be odds with
some of radomir Putin's values and
Oliver Stone the famous director has
done a series of interviews with him I
know Gregor help you imagine the review
but there were some quotes from the
interviews in The Times today and here's
some here's some quotes Oliver Stone
asked mr. Putin whether he ever has a
day off and this is the the president
says I'm not a woman so I don't have bad
days I'm not trying to insult anyone
that's the nature of things they have
certain natural cycles which men
probably have as well just less
manifested we are all human beings it's
normal but you should never lose control
suggesting that perhaps women don't cope
as well as men do in these situations
because of their natural I'm using in
the West no one shares that do but it's
not politically correct to say it I mean
I did you know okay there are a lot of
people who feel that way you know I'm
not here to support Boonton believe me
so that is you know that's you know I
don't I am sharing that that almost like
a very sexist view for the president
agree and to say so exactly on a
national platform that's probably agree
with you all right though he clearly
doesn't worry about being how he's
perceived not even know that in the West
there would be a reaction to that do you
really think it's a possibility this is
not part of what is really bad but he's
not a naive person either he's a very
bright intelligent man that has reminded
the country were saying things like that
he must know that's going to gauge a
reaction yeah I think he does he sees a
will he's to career intelligence officer
who spent spent its entire life in
combat in meeting me so I would expect
them to have some understanding of our
broader society can I quickly come back
to the earlier question about proof in
terms of the manipulating of our
election and perhaps of yours and of the
French the Germans and all the
directions are everywhere no sir
tomorrow actually modern technology
allows the Russian Federation to do
something that they have traditionally
been associated with on a massive scale
the us tonight in terms of the raw
capacity out there yes that's what we're
talking well well actually actually one
of the one of my faults is director of
CIA was not that I meddled too much in
Russian Affairs one of my faults as
director of CIA was I hardly paid any
attention to Russia but yet no we did
not
and and yet you think I spent every
morning on the seventh floor at Langley
all waking moments figuring out ways to
make Vladimir Putin's life less pleasant
than it would otherwise be again if we
had a fault I should have paid more
attention you've been doing that notice
fascinating hearing from the two of you
I know that you're you're doing a debate
tonight aren't you tell us where you're
doing a debate I'll leave you in query
doable yeah yes the tube you'll be
debating this and I'm sure it'd be out
for us portly video another tune and
we're going to be on different size yes
you don't believe that we have got to
really enjoy that I posed them in the
form of direct to the CIA and they say a
General Michael Hayden thanks for
joining us alone - thank you